point and we talked a lot about it and
um I told her what our reservations are
we both felt that it was important and
we felt we should work together to
create
something um at that point um
representative lungren um took it took
up the flag representative py said she
she wasn't going to do it um for variety
of reasons and he did and he basically
took the same bill and I don't really
know what happened last session I'm a
little bit lost on this tabled versus
retained versus whatever but the bill
wasn't killed but it was it was retained
and so he was able to bring it back this
session in the meantime um we again at
the med Society legislative committee at
that point I was not a legislator um we
looked at this bill in detail and we had
a lot of concerns about it but we we
valued the the premise of it so we
convened an ad hoc group that consisted
of
myself um U Mike padmore from the med
Society s Savage um um who I think you
both know um and um um Cindy Steinberg
and the reason why we included Cindy was
that she's a friend of mine we've been
worked together for years she's the
legislative director for both the US
pain foundation and the Massachusetts
pain initiative they'd worked on a
similar bill in Massachusetts and um um
uh or a similar concept very
conceptually similar um and so we wanted
to build on what they had done and the
ne thing about the Massachusetts bill is
that as a result of that or direct
result of that it's increased access to
a lot of these
Services um in in a very public way and
so it really has had good
ramifications so we we sat down went
through the whole thing together and to
be honest we eliminated about 90% of his
bill and um um um like for example the
first opening paragraph of this bill is
just a premise that says a doctor May do
all this well we may do it now anyways
and then the second premise is we have
to fill a form out you know which is
totally voluntary and and
superficially that frankly is
micromanaging medicine and and the
medical society was totally opposed to
that I was totally opposed to that um
the voluntary element of it didn't make
any sense to me and um and the other
little Minor Detail is if you look at
the controlled substance Act and the
rules that are in the controlled
substance Act we have to do that already
so it's already in statute it really
didn't make any sense so as we kept
going through it you know it kept
getting more and more bogged down and
then he the bill goes into um you know
the alternative services that can or
should be provided or whatever and so at
that point we're starting to realize
yeah that has value but not the way it's
written so what we decided to do we had
we had to make we had decide on our
strategy did we want to just re write
the entire Bill did we want to work with
him on the bill who did we want to work
with so we brought together a whole
bunch of stakeholders the uh New
Hampshire acupuncture Association New
Hampshire Chiropractic
Association um the psych people I can't
remember what their acronym is but um
and we brought together all these people
and figured it out and that's where 303
came from House Bill 303 it was all of
us working together to come up with this
bill
so then we I we we tried to include um
representative lungren in those
discussions um we we eventually shared
303 with him and said we need to
reconcile these two bills and in the end
um we never got a response and in the
end all he did was he added 303 to the
end of his bill and so at this point um
I didn't even know he was going to do
that and so um the deadline was
approaching so I just submitted 303 cuz
I thought I was losing my window and
then all of a sudden 303 goes into
Commerce and I don't really fully get
why this bill came to
HHS I I understand the opening part yes
but the second part's Commerce so I
didn't understand that but then that
bill came to us so um at this point what
I kind of think we really need to do is
number one is decide can we reconcile
these two bills and the reason why I
think it's I I really appreciate
everything representative maputi and
representative lren have done it's like
really important their actions have
actually spawned two bills they
spawned 303 and they also spawned 66 and
they really deserve a lot of credit for
that and I really appreciate that at the
same
point I think the bill has a lot of
flaws that
303 and there's an amended version of
303 303 will not pass as is but we've
amended it and we think it has some
value that and the insurers and us find
valuable um I I haven't talked to you
guys yet about that stuff but um at the
same point we really recognize their
issues as well as ours and so um I think
that's kind of where we're at do we want
to go through this bill piece by piece
and cross out stuff and try to salvage
what's left or do we want to itl it and
just go with
303 I think represent no repr I'll just
leave it at that that's all I have to
say so 303 is still before Commerce
correct and that was retained by
Commerce
yes um we've they had a hearing about
that I I I it's not up to me to speak
for them
um there's a there is a lot of support
for it um and that's why the amendment's
important because the original Bell had
a lot of shout
the shells got changed to Maze and
that's kind of the big change in that um
um um and the other thing that was also
important that was critical in terms of
our discussions is that any
services that were included in this had
to be provided by licensed
practitioners so and I agree with that I
think that makes total sense so there
were movement therapies like Chiang um
Tai Chi there's mindbody therapies that
are in there none of that's done by a
licensed provider so and yoga is in
there also um with that all was
removed um the Behavioral Medicine was
included
um um acupuncture massage
Chiropractic um this bill also includes
Physical Therapy um and occupational
therapy and naturopathy and I don't know
that those things are necessary because
they're covered
elsewhere um but we can if you want we
can go through this paragraph by
paragraph or whatever you want to do but
I want to hear what you guys think I
guess the question I'd asked the
committee repr Nagel we have House Bill
66 there's a committee working on this
somewhat I find the commonality but also
where the two
diverge the commonality as we're talking
about trying to find ways to help
patients with nonopiate
processes in a lot of goes back to
chronic pain the difference I see here
though this is looking at it broadly and
not trying to come up with a pilot
program and my concern is that when you
start looking at things broadly because
it's sort of untested we don't have a
lot of um documentation to support the
expansion of it is it better for us to
continue to work with House Bill 66
which is coming out of the committee and
take that recommendation from the
committee and build into that pilot
program some of the principles you have
here in
303 and and I will say that you know
everybody I I travel all over the
country speaking on these issues and we
use the alternative to opioids as a flag
waving thing to get people's attention
it's really not the reason why this bill
is here this bill is here is because
chiropractors feel that they've been cut
out of the pie and they want back in and
and that's the real reason and and you
know that that's the the base reason why
this bill exists the and they decided to
include all these other folks as well um
you know my only concern with HP 66 is
like what population of people are we
trying to serve with that we're looking
at integrative models of care for
complex problems chiropractors and
acupuncturist want to be included with
the simple problems too like for example
when I negotiated a contract years ago
with Health Source to cover
acupuncture they made a stipulation that
the only patients that I could see were
the patients that had failed everything
else which is like okay great give me a
patient that I'm not going to succeed
with either it made no sense but you
know you you take what you can get um
they want access to patients a lot
earlier than that and I think HB 66 is
really dealing with people who are more
complicated if I'm not
if if if we're trying to through HB
303 to expand it so we
have more opportunity for patients to go
to a chiropractor or go to acupunctur I
would say at that point in time narrow
the scope down to that and that only and
then so take 303 pair it back and at
that point in time that makes sense to
me yeah we paired 303 back quite a bit
and we can pair it back more there's
like Behavioral Medicine and massage in
there yeah
um we've really not gotten any inclusion
in our efforts from the folks from
behavioral Med although they're very
thrilled that we included them I've got
virtually no feedback from massage folks
so but the chiropractors and acupunctur
have been intimately involved with the
entire process and I I I kind of wish
that they were here um I to speak for
themselves cuz I don't feel comfortable
speaking for them um so I won't say what
they think but um I know what they
think but again if it says may instead
of shall right my understanding is most
of the health care policies out there
have the ability to do it which is May
and therefore I'm not sure exactly what
this will achieve because the insurance
companies can may do it today if they
want to which is different than shall
which is a
mandate um I yes
this was
not this job is not easy and um
I that's a long story about how it got
from sh's De Ma and I
I um with great reluctance I agreed to
that so
um thanks for bringing me up two things
the the behavioral health just I mean um
I've been studying for the boards and um
for a great many conditions including
chronic pain that's definitely one of
the recommended things and it's one of
the things that's very hard to get and
admittedly in rural areas one of the
reasons is I mean has less to do with
well I guess maybe it has to do with
insurance company insurance coverage but
there just aren't the practitioners a
lot of the time
um now I forgot what the other thing was
um oh and the only thing the other thing
was um does was changing from sh to May
does that mean that we're looking at
prior
off
because that's the
evil um that's a totally interestingly
great segue to a very separate very
long-winded very heavily multi-person
involved discussion that I think is
above and beyond what we're talking
about here but I don't disagree I mean
even if it's a shall or it's a may
there's still could be a prior
authorization one way or the other I um
I mean I think the prior authorization
issue is something that we really want
to resolve as a group you know not just
you know us against them type thing
because it is a problem for everybody
and Mr chair one of the things I learned
along this journey that I found
fascinating when you think about what
state of law actually can govern within
Healthcare insurance it's a small slice
of the pie because we cannot impact
Medicare A lot of things with Orissa are
outside of the scope of it so when you
start thinking about the large or small
employer Marketplace and so forth is
probably M scoll if you can help me out
here with these numbers but I believe
it's probably around 30% if that so when
we when you talk about things here we
want actually to impact that the patient
level It's relatively small slice of the
pie not small but 25 to 30% of the
pie 25 thank you I'm going about to say
something nice to you guys but like um I
I really seriously believe that um our
Health Care system is headed in a wrong
direction I think we're seeing both
Corporation in health care and
insurance and and I personally think
that the private insurers have an
incredibly important role to play as we
go forward and I'm really concerned
about doing anything that would
adversely affect their role so I do
respect what you guys do um and and
that's one of the other reasons for the
sh May thing I think
um so but I'm sorry I go ahead go ahead
I'm sorry so just um for strategy so we
have 554 which is
basically uh representative lungren Bill
plus 303 tacked on to it and then 303
and is there a rational having sort of
the same bill in two different
committees and if if if so I mean would
it I mean would you look at like just
amending 554 to being more like just
303 and that
or I I'm G to let you answer that
because I don't know I I that's
something I've really struggled with I
get to because I'm a freshman I get to
ask question
this it's a really great question uh if
that was to occur the way I would read
that we'd have literally two competing
bills one in Commerce and one in Health
Human Services and LLY Affairs and
unless both committees pass it it's
probably going to have a challenge on
the floor it's depending upon how they
come out of the committee and what
happens at that point in time when the
scheduling process so if you want to
look at retaining or at least working on
303 and coming out of this committee
then I would to representative Palmer's
point which is a good one is to strip
out
504 and leave in it only
303 and that way there we have at least
a shot of it getting through this
committee to get onto the floor but
after to recognize it's also in Commerce
it may come out of the Commerce with the
competing recommend Commendation
so wow I mean this is what my thinking
was coming into our meeting today was I
I went I don't know what I did with it
but I have a copy of this that I exed
out a lot of the I mean basically when I
it's no different I actually looked at
my copy of this from five years ago and
I went through the same thing did the
same thing and I exed out that whole
reporting stuff which is about a third
of the bill I decided when he looked at
all all of how his insurance coverage
stuff I said this is kind of nebulous
and hard to follow it's better described
in 303 so I eliminated that twitched it
over to 303 and then the opening preface
while I think it has value it really
doesn't say anything because I can do it
already so it didn't it didn't change
medical it made no sense to me to put
something in a statue that already
exists so basically in the end all I had
was 303 that was left and and then I was
thinking well I was going to cross out
303 total because I didn't think it
should be in two bills and all of a
sudden I don't have a bill at all you
know except a title and um and so in the
end my recommendation was to itl this
and let it go through Commerce and I
really didn't want to do that because I
really appreciate everything that do
represented lr's done I think is
important but and this is really
important to him and I really wish we'd
had a much better you know communication
about this from the very beginning but
it didn't happen so I so I I think we
have two options we either it all this
go with Commerce or we strip out a lot
of this and then have two competing
Bills or the other thing I think you
could possibly do is talk to the
chairman of Commerce and see if they
willing to um redirect that 303 back
here given the fact that we're going to
fundamentally we take out 504 have 303
and two committees and ask at that point
in time would he redirect it over here
if that's possible um we can ask and I'm
pretty sure I already know the answer
answer that but we've had that
discussion and the other the other issue
concern ourselves with the fact that we
have two bills that are comparable to
each other the wording in each bill may
not be identical so therefore when it
gets to that point in time my
understanding is it's the last version
that gets past it becomes the uh
Foundation upon which we do things but
don't forget this even if it goes out of
the house still has to go to the
Senate I'm kind of really starting to
like what you guys are
suggesting that we just except that we
our recommendation is to keep the
amended version of 303 and eliminate
everything
else that would my recommendation is
take 504
out 554 sorry and then at that point in
time leave 303 and we'll run the risk at
that point in time of having two bills
one in each committee
um so um I'm sorry go ahead bill you I'm
I'm
monopolizing well and we don't and we
don't know if com Commerce may itl this
bill so it may not
so that is so smart and I'll be honest
you know um I I've been so empowered
with a lot of the stuff that I've been
doing because I get this impression that
there's this stigma in the in this in
against people in pain in the
legislature and and I think it's a false
perception because like between the opio
to baitman commission meetings when you
know you start with a single voice
questioning what we're doing and why
we're doing it and then all of a sudden
people start coming gradually out of the
closet and saying you know what you're
right and on the house floor when we
looked at that whole issue of harm red
uction and people started coming out of
the closet just because people on the
Commerce Committee and I'm not saying
that they would vote against this bill
but you know it may be that we have a
lot more support than we think we've got
because everybody has
pain and um I mean if you don't you're
weird but not everybody has chronic pain
but there's a lot of people in the
legislature that do have chronic pain or
know somebody
does so are we leaning towards a
recommendation to strip out 550 4 and
leave 303 but it's still called 554
correct yes yeah which is which that
would be my dream and I think that could
be helpful strategically because if it's
554 it's not the same as 303
so and and and so this would require an
amendment that we would have to write
and that um and and and I would probably
make because the the amendment that I
gave to you guys I wrote so um but it
was it was given to me by um folks in
Commerce after their meeting that they
were leaning towards supporting it with
the Maze and shs the next question is
should I leave the shs in and our bill
whereas they of the
maze
um so on my notes here when we when we
heard
554 um I there there's the May and I I
had um I think people questioned whether
we should make it shall back then
um it's a tough call I I mean I again it
I don't want to
ostracize do we have public hearing at
these things all of the
chair I mean more than happy to hear
from either of you guys if you want to
say share your
thoughts I should have done that right
in the beginning I'm sorry I'm not good
at this oh I did get my picture taken up
here so that was pretty
exciting be honest this is the way I
look at things um I just think that
we're we should be one big happy family
I know we have differences of opinion on
stuff it seems to me that the the shell
is a better at this point than a May
thing um and that's why it would kind of
I mean the May is better than a shell
whatever you know what I meant um and I
would lean towards just leing it the way
I have it amended and because that was
the recommendation that was given to me
by the folks in
Commerce I I think from
a strategy point of view there'll be
less opposition to the word may than the
word shall secondly if it becomes a
mandate because of the word shell then I
don't know what that does
with the um Affordable Care Act because
the certain things in provision within
the federal government government versus
state government so state does certain
things that is beyond the maintenance of
the federal government how that works
out that I don't know but the word may
minimizes that
impact um the other thing I do want to
point out also is that the language that
at the end of the 303 section which
talks about and and you guys have
educated me a lot on this but the
insurers have to provide transparent
information about what you have for
services available and things like that
our reasoning behind that is that you
know um we're trying to
empower we have this General belief that
patients really don't get the care that
they need in an integrative way and the
only way they can get it is to empower
them with the knowledge that they need
to manage their own problems and so um
that language is basically in there to
empower them to know what their
insurance is provide them um that
language in Massachusetts I think was
largely responsible for increasing
access to certain services that they
wouldn't have gotten otherwise although
in Massachusetts there was a mandate I
believe that they had to provide one of
these things um and that was a
compromise over a long period of time um
we're under the understanding that many
of these policies already include some
of these things um we put an the other
thing is that we discussed the number
the amended version took the number from
20 of each of these things per year to
12 and that was a compromise also I was
going to ask that question as well R of
Nel it says 12 from
each versus 20 in total 12 in total
versus if you take 12 times whatever the
each is that could be 36 to 48 so it's
in how to tweak it and saying are we
looking at being prescriptive and saying
has to come from each one or we looking
at saying there's the basket of 20 and
the patient or the provider has the
opportunity to choose amongst the 20 and
use them accordingly because some
patients may want more than 12 with
acupuncture but you can't do that
because 12's sort of the limit if you
make it 20 or 24 whatever it may
be collectively in the aggregate that
allows more
flexibility I think if you're going to
do that I would make a number higher
than 20 but I don't disagree with what
you're saying I mean for some patients
they just need one of these things for
other patients they're going to need all
three together you know like we have a
lot of chronic pain patients that we
need a behavioral therapy plus uh
Chiropractic or osteopathic adjustment
the reason why osteopathy wasn't
included in this was because they
already have their own thing but um or
PT for that matter too I mean you know I
mean we thought about including them
also but they're already separately
included they weren't part of this
discussion but um but yeah a lot of
patients get multiple modalities at the
same time and and so if we come up with
a number I would use the number 36 that
would be the number I would pick if we
say cumulative total 36 I think is a
reasonable
number
um and you know the other little Minor
Detail that we learned at our L last HB
66 meeting sorry we're speaking behind
your back a little bit on this
representative palmer but like um you
know the worst person you're going to go
see for an acute back problem is a spine
surgeon because they're expensive and
they don't know anything and it's
nothing personal but if you don't need
surgery they don't know anything about
conservative care and granted there's
some that do but for the most part
they've never even been in a PT gym so
or certainly at a chiropractor's office
and they always talk about the magic of
physiatry and I always say it's fun to
read their notes because they talk about
oh we're going to send them to physiatry
for whatever it is they do and I was
like going I don't know what it is that
I do but I'm I'm glad that I'm magical
but um but they showed us data that
actually to see a
chiropractor fory cute back problem
especially with the way chiropractors
are now as opposed to the way they were
historically historically it was like
shake and bake type stuff but but now
it's it's really more holistic Ken and
and it's much more cost effective than
even in a physical therapist and part of
the reason why I think there and I is
that pts are dependent on a doctor's
script and I think that's a problem that
needs to be fixed also but at the same
point it's much more coste effective to
do it that way um as an acupuncturist my
best outcomes were seeing people right
away not like three years later you know
to see them right away before they're
neurologically plasticized so that
there's really very little I can do for
them you know um and I want to have
access to those people now not later and
I think I can be a lot
cheaper than a you know an orthopedic
surgeon or or whatever um mostly because
an orthop guy is expensive yeah um one
of the um if I may there's still a word
shell if you look at the uh second sheet
if you will where it has the number of
visits oh is that you want to retain
that as shall or you talking about May
are you on the um U number two policies
issued and
renewed um I'm sorry you on the actual
bill or you on your
Amendment
see because if you go down to page two
afterwards on four it talks about May
provide so they're not consistent
is the very top
line you're
right hang around with smart people like
you you're a smart
guy
if we're in agreement then I'll prepare
an amendment to this bill that we're
going to just stick with the 303
language eliminate everything else and
that way we get everything because
representative lr's name stays on the
bill which is really important to me um
so is that
fair sure yeah I think you have to
because she said we're being
recorded
the brains of this whole operation are
behind that laptop over there she's not
listening
um good morning uh let me move over so I
can a little bit um good morning uh my
name is Heidi croll I work at Gallagher
C Hanah gartell and I represent um ahip
which is America's health insurance
plans and we've been you know
participating in the house bill 66 um
study committee work um and so
appreciate the opportunity so um
H having been in the Commerce side of
this and getting bits and pieces of the
conversation that um I wasn't directly
part of the conversation get getting
bits and pieces about the conversation
about maybe changing the shells to maze
um I think chairman hunt
has um a paired down version in his mind
of what that meant to him versus what
this might reflect
um so I think what he was looking toward
is uh in other areas of the statute
where we already do have coverage for
like PT OT chiropractors that sort of
thing just trying to
mirror that exist using that kind of as
a template and mirroring that for some
of these other
um uh providers or Services um with the
May in instead of shs so um for example
in this draft there's um a section that
kind of addresses network adequacy but
we already have laws on the books um
around Network adequacy so like that
piece wouldn't be necessary as an
example
um sorry I'm gonna pull this staple
apart it's in the wrong spot
so
just to make sure I understand you're
looking at the amendment that I wrote up
yes
okay
um
so this is
in um excuse me I've got a frog in my
throat this is in Roman 5 on for me it's
page two um and it would be replicated
um later um so there's different
statutes one for um the individual
market and then one for um group The
Group market of insurance um
um so it it's it's repeated um later in
the bill as well but that's the ad the
you know the network adequacy piece that
that would not be necessary um I mean I
think the other pieces in here like
filing I think there's a piece in here
about filing a comprehensive plan
um uh Pain Services management plan with
the Department that has to be approved
and that like I think those kind of
components like I I don't know that
chairman hunt was envisioning okay those
sorts of other things I think he was
thinking of a very kind of paired back
more so anyway I just wanted to to flag
that for you folks
um that that might no I really
appreciate that um and I really feel bad
because I haven't been able to attend
any of those meetings and um I'm
planning on doing my best to get to the
next one so at least I can listen to
what they're saying if not participating
so just just um so you're aware so the
committee so there was a um a full
committee had um a work session I guess
if you will on all of their retain bills
so during the work session the decision
was to retain um continue to retain uh
house bill
um uh 303 and so I think it was only
afterwards um when the committee had
dispersed um that um uh
representative collabor yes thank you um
had mentioned to to representative hunt
that she might be interested in I guess
maybe trying to do something with it so
it was very much a kind of a sidebar
conversation it was not a discussion
amongst the the whole committee so it
was one of these ideas kind of a three
minute conversation kind of over on the
side of the room so anyway just to to
let you know but um I think there are
pieces in here that um either duplicate
what we already have in current law or
would conflict with what we current H
have in current law or just kind of went
outside of the scope of what the
chairman might have been thinking that
where his vision was going so um and for
example like with chiro Chiropractic
services like we already have something
on the on the books around that um and I
just did want to say I went was digging
through my emails before um when know
was sitting there listening to you so
um not this past summer but the summer
before there's this ad hoc group that I
think both of you were part of um around
this same topic and so a pres we the
insurance companies gave a
presentation um which we will probably
give a similar version of um to the
houseful 66 committee at some point um
but one of the things that we had was um
a little chart that we gave you about
what the insurance company um currently
do cover because I think there is kind
of a Mis understanding
or a tendency to think we're not
covering anything when in fact we are
you know covering so um Chiropractic
Services um are covered PT is covered um
tens units um are covered acupuncture
coverage varies and the other thing I
think to keep in mind is that
um you know carriers have many different
plans that they offer so um part of that
is that some plans um might have
coverage and other plans might not and
for people to make a decision about you
know is it something they want included
in their coverage or not and and they've
weighed the premiums and they weigh the
services that are included so um
acupuncture coverage varies um gym
membership coverage varies uh
massage um as a standalone service tends
not to be covered but if it is part of
uh Cairo or PT or OT then it is covered
so again this is you know I don't get to
go with my girlfriends to the spa and
get my massage covered by Insurance um
and then uh meditation This was um
another thing that we had provided um
each of the insurance companies or the
major ones anyway that that help pull
this together um Harvard Pilgrim um
Sigma and Anthem all have a wealth of
resources on their websites um around um
uh meditation and
um kind of um management
[Music]
um techniques that people can use um so
they offer written materials videos and
that's all for free on their websites
and it's not limited to members so
anybody could be doing a Google search
and find that so I just wanted to kind
of remind folks that there is quite a
bit of coverage already um I think the
piece that the house bll 66 study has
been working on is more of the
integrated piece around that so um
anyway I'm happy to try to answer any
questions but I just wanted to share
that with you yes thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking the
question one of the things that I
believe is starting to come to my
attention anyways and me getting to
understand from a patient's point of
view it's hard to understand what they
have in their plan per se because
there's so many labors of
plans is there any way we could can
begin to think
about standardizations give an example
of something with Medicare you have
different supplemental insurance options
but each one of the options a b c and so
forth they're standardized within that
option
so the patient begins to understand if
you take that option what you're going
to have for an option regardless of your
supplemental coverage is there any way
within New Hampshire we could begin to
think about some of this and saying
these are the
standards and all you have to do at that
point in time is if you want to offer
standard a these are what's in the plan
if you want B that's what's in the plan
to help minimize the fragmentation about
how things come across to the patient
sorry I hope that was on before
um I think part of the challenge with
that is that you know this is a
competitive market so um I think there
is a lot of commonality
across plans that carriers offer whether
it's in the individual Market or in the
small group or large group markets and
again these are all the fully insured
products um as you mentioned
um self-funded um is you know that's
those are employer sponsored where the
employer is taking the risk um and so
they have a lot more um freedom to
develop their plans and what they're
going to cover and that sort of thing
but um so in terms of standardizing I'm
not sure just because it is a
competitive market but I do know that um
plans do make available to the me ERS
you know there's a kind of a a chart um
I get it every year you know through my
employer um of what's covered and
co-pays and that sort of thing so you
know they do try to simplify it as much
as possible in terms of what is covered
and um any if if there is a member um
co-pay or or co- inssurance follow up
thank you I do understand the issue
about Market
competition however if each one of the
plans is
standardized at that point in time the
competition would be the same because if
you're going to offer plan a you're
competing on plan a if you want B you're
still competing with Plan B I think from
a patience point of view it allows them
to understand the variance between them
and starts to narrow down so
sanitization I think by itself would not
prohibit competition probably would
encourage competition increase the
competition within that particular
standard yeah and I think I think um I
mean like when people are going onto the
um into the ACA Marketplace you know
there there are standard formats where
people can look and look at those the
charts that I'm talking about and
compare and contrast so I think that's
there um but I'm not
sure we're going so far as to mandate
that every single carrier has to offer
plan A B C and D and in those a plans
ABC and D are these
elements gets a little um my intent was
not to force the carrier to offer a b c
d and so forth but if you're going to
offer a this is the bundle of things
that you're offering to the patient
population and therefore the competition
is based upon the bundle yeah not based
upon the individual fragmentation at
that point in time is trying to help the
consumer become more educated about how
to compare plan a to plan B A lot of
times consumer is not the patient
themselves is the employer
yeah well I mean I'm just thinking of
going back to
um Medicare and the problem I one of the
big problems I think is not so much you
know that plans offer you know that you
can look up in your plan and see what's
there is that nobody looks and Medicare
um for example there's the 3-day rule so
you have to be hospitalized for three
acute days before you qualify for a
swing stay in in most circumstances and
that's kind of across the board and the
number of Medicare patients
who understand that rule when they end
up in the hospital is about zero and so
I I mean I I think a transparency is is
really important but probably in order
to get to having
people understand and the other thing I
was thinking is this way is like um I'd
be looking at a plan and i' I'd go
Chiropractic I I I'm not going to need
that but little do I know that when I
stack firewood next winter I'm going to
change my mind so I mean I think it's a
little I mean it's great when there's a
chart you can look at and decide up
front if particularly if you know
conditions
but I yeah I mean
um I guess when I'm thinking is like how
making sure that services are available
that are you know medically accepted and
proven is is I think the thing that is
really most important and then
um I think then patients are going to be
sort of in the same boat of in and when
they're trying to pick a plan if when
they have a choice
um um
having to find out having to ask their
doctor who won't know having to you
know I just so you know I'm sorry did
you want to respond I was just going to
say uh that is covered I mean there we
we do have we do have that in law sorry
that was I picked a bad example
Y and yeah I it's
it's I'm I'm I'm about to turn 65 I know
I don't look it I have to pick medic
care plans and I'm clueless so I I I you
know in the b in the end basically
people just look at the dollar figure
they're going to pay and it's amazing
every day that all the patient come in
he says you know what I had no idea I
just know what I could afford and I
never even looked at anything else but
that and I don't know how you solve that
problem because unfortunately I think
it's becoming more and more and more
complicated like I do I even want a
supplemental Medicare plan or or
whatever you know do I even need it you
know but and which one and and yeah I
unfortunately for me my employer will
pay for it for 5 years so we have to I
retire so it's not like it's a big deal
to me but rep of Nel and rep pal you
both raised some really good points part
of it comes down to is historically most
patients rely upon the employer to make
the choice for them Y and when they get
into the situation whether it's the
individual Market or whether it's
through Medicare they'll lost and to
your point they don't really understand
how to read the policies and understand
what's before them so part of it going
to be patient education which is
definitely going to be a different tack
altogether I did Al oh go ahead did you
have a yeah I was just going to Echo the
point that representative Merchant made
earlier which I just want to make sure
everybody heard um so the the rsas that
you're talking about here are um fully
insured individual Market small group
and large group and that's at best about
only 25% of the market in New Hampshire
so the remainder is Medicaid Medicare um
the VA um
uninsured uh the the self-funded um is
actually a growing segment of the market
as um more and more um requirements and
mandates get put on the fully insured
products um it used to be that only the
very largest of employers you know like
State and municipalities and very very
large businesses were in the the
self-funded market and
as mandates have increased and the costs
have gone up you see medium and even
smaller sized businesses going into the
um the self-funded market because they
decide that at some point they decide
it's worth the risk to be to be there so
I just wanted to and it's actually
something that the insurance department
is um paying more and more attention to
in terms of the um the small group
Market is dwindling and um it's a
concern because as it dwindles um you
kind of have the potential for things to
kind of spiral you know the the
proverbial death spiral I'm not saying
we're there but I'm saying it's
something that's on their radar and so I
just wanted to again reiterate what this
piece of legislation what slice of the
market you would be hitting and and um
historically um whenever the house
Commerce has or either Commerce
Committee the senate or the house have
considered new mandates um they have
excluded the individual Market um
because in a post AA World um any new
mandates imposed by a state after so
you've got the the federal government
obviously um there's lots of
opportunities for for subsidies and that
sort of thing but if a state imposes a
new mandate the cost of that that um
this the federal government will not
subsidize and it's a state obligation so
the state is tended to shy away from
putting mandates new mandates onto the
individual market so mandates that we've
seen in the last you know however many
years since the ACA it's it's been even
more narrow and only focused on small
group and large group so um just things
to consider and and I know this I think
in part that's why um your bill house
bille 303 was sent to the Commerce
Committee because they yeah um they're
well-versed in all this so I really
appreciate everything you said this
whole process been extremely educ oh can
I talk sure you want to talk just a
question as I listen to this
conversation if we change the shells to
May which I told
support at the end of the day how is
that different than what we have
today that is a really awesome question
am I allowed to say awesome um because I
had the same question because the person
that suggested that I do that I look at
it I go what did we actually accomplish
here um and I'm not really sure um this
is but we will accomplish something and
um and that's what a question or comment
that I really wanted to make was so in
full disclosure you know I I know I'm a
legislator but I also represent
acupuncturists um not as a l well maybe
way I do but um I I'm on the legislative
committee Nel yeah you're not a lobbyist
you can advocate for yourself for your
profession within the legislative body
but you're definitely not a lobbyist
that is true that is true but I've
worked with the American Academy medical
acupuncture for a long time um so this
is an issue that we've talked about for
a very long time and also the driving
force behind this legislation is
actually the chiropractors who feel and
and this is my observation of 35 years
in New Hampshire is that they've
gradually become crowded out more and
more so like when I first started like I
mean to see you know 24 visits a year
paid for wasn't unusual now they don't
get that and and that's really
frustrating for them and they're the
ones that are really driving this
conversation so I think that they would
you've been at the hearings they would
contradict a lot of what you've said um
so I kind of feel like that's you know
we're we're speaking on their behalf I'm
concerned that with the maze the shells
that we're not going to accomplish what
they want to accomplish but it it
achieves some middle ground and maybe
that's something it it's
something rep of Neel I would say
that maybe part of the issue that
they're feeling crowded out comes down
to as people talked about before as the
market moves more into
Arisa which then is determined by the
employer not by the insurance company
themselves because they said if I
understand it correctly they said the
guidelines of the plan and that they're
trying to find ways to reduce the cost
that may be one of the opportunities for
them to reduce the cost of the plan
number two which I don't know totally
but assuming that more and more people
go into Medicare Advantage versus
tradition traditional that comes under
the HMO model within Medicare and those
models may also start to begin to impact
the chiropractice themselves so it could
be a shift in the marketplace because of
healthc care Dynamics and economics
that's causing some of the unlying
problem they're
facing go ahead yeah um so there's two
things I just wanted to add thank you
for letting me jump in um so one thing I
was going to say is that
um uh Laur employers that are
self-funded um I think by and large um
use third-party administrators tpas um
to actually administer their um their
plans so even though the company itself
or the municipality or the St or whoever
the entity is is taking the risk
associated with the insurance they're
they have somebody else doing all the
administrative work and so my
understanding is that
um while the self fun funed um entities
are not required you know there are not
mandates on them like there are on the
fully insured plans um because these
third party administrators like siga
like Anthem um other uh United probably
um they they operate both as third party
administrators as well as in the large
group and small group um perhaps even
the individual markets as well they will
often bring their um the covered
Services as a template to those large
employers so I just wanted to say that I
think for example chiropractic care I
think is pretty well like standardized
at this point in terms of being covered
um so that's one thing I wanted to say
the other thing I wanted to say that
we've heard from the chiropractors and
perhaps other um service providers kind
of that fall into the fields that you're
looking at here
um is
they and they have testified to this
that they will often choose to stay out
of network and not contract with
insurance companies and so I I just
wanted to point that out that it's
another reason when you're asking like
what effect will this legislation have
um so moving from sh to May def you know
on the one hand I guess you could argue
it it's on the book still that's kind of
rais elevating I guess elevating the the
opportunity um but to the extent that
providers are staying out of network
this will not apply to them so they they
are preferring to have um cash pay
patients and not not deal with um
insurance at all so I just wanted to say
that when you overlay that onto this 25%
of the market or less um you're getting
to a very a smaller and smaller sliver
so I I'm really glad you said that
because the point that I wanted to make
was you know I I've talked all over the
country to chiropractic and massage or
acupuncture groups about this and the
question I've asked them in large groups
is why do you want to be insured or why
do you want insurance at all you got a
great system right now you you know you
get cash you don't have to deal with
forms you don't have to go through
insurers you don't have to do this that
or the other thing you seem to be doing
fine and guess what you're happy CU I
swear one of the reasons why uh provid
ERS um you know lose their happiness in
providing care is all the forms the
prior authorizations so on and so forth
and is you have any of that you've got a
great life what's the matter and their
response is that they want access to a
greater portion of the market the people
that can't afford their services which
then doesn't come down to you it comes
down to Medicare Medicaid and things
like that which is I think why with HB
66 we want to f focus on that group and
and that and I and I'm I'm really glad
you said everything you said because it
it brought into very perspective how
damage I I shouldn't say this publicly
but how challenging the Affordable Care
Act has been for your industry and for
all of us and when we look at
skyrocketing Insurance costs that are
adversely affecting pretty much
everybody you know it's important to
hear that message on a regular basis and
that's why I was really sensitive to not
wanting to burden you with this
um does it make sense it does d Nel I I
think this here is trying
to if you want to call it fix or to
modify what exists
today what I think about House Bill 66
is trying to look at a fundamental shift
into something that's truly integrated
and using a pilot using a small segment
of the market to learn from it I think
it could step down to not just the
integration of the providers and how we
communicate amongst the providers but
also the payment model that goes with it
so I I really think I'd rather put more
of our effort into house bill 66 than
try to go down this road if we leave the
word may versus shall I don't think this
is really going to change things
significantly it's more of a window
dressing in my
opinion so let me ask you a question to
follow up at this point that pretty much
guts the entire bill so are you
advocating that we just itl it I would
say after this l ly lengthy conversation
and your knowledge and your wisdom yes I
would say the recommendation should be
to itl
it no I I I I I I don't I think that was
extremely
helpful I was hoping that you two would
come and talk
you're always helpful and thoughtful I I
felt the same way because when that made
a sh thing is like well why bother you
know what's the whole point
um I was going to say something Beyond
intelligent I forgot what it was the
world have probably ceased to exist now
because I didn't remember what I was
going to
say um May I so one question
I have is obviously if if we could
figure out that a bill like this was
going to reduce costs overall um and and
the the I mean the media problem is if
we you know keep one person from
becoming opiate
dependent that I mean there's a dollar
cost to that but but also there's a big
human cost which you can't maybe measure
in dollar but um I'm just wondering down
the road whether
we you know like there there's all of
the the the studies about which care is
the best care for a given situation and
increasingly we're um looking towards a
more behavioral approach or even
preventative approaches to this
obviously once you have an injury and
you have pain now we got to figure it
out but even there like you were talking
about back pain is that physical therapy
and and um and Chiropractic are often
the the best route for sort of
traditional low back pain as opposed to
some more you know doing x-rays and
using medications and or you know more
than Tylenol or or uprof or something so
I'm just wondering
whether it one way to look at this is
how to how to come if we're not going to
go with this how to come back with
something that looks at more at um
how you how you sort of force people
more into doing what is the actual high
value medicine and away from low value
care um and maybe you C and particularly
when we're looking at a small percentage
of the the people less than 25% um how
how do we how might we approach this to
get more of this care that is probably
cheaper long term to to the people who
need it the most so if I can answer that
question you basically the whole premise
of my book is based on what you just
asked um and I will ask the insurers
this because I've asked you this at
every meeting we've ever
had um Everybody Wants evidence-based
care I have no clue what that even means
I wrote a whole thing on facts and
fallacies of evidence-based medic Medic
in in the in the book and it was
actually a standalone chapter at one
point because it was really important to
me you know evidence base is based on
whoever is providing the evidence and
like like for example like like in
Interventional pain management we've
been doing it now for 35 years we have
like no evidence that anything that we
do Works anything more than a short
period at time and and many of the
interventions are extremely costly
extremely invasive I'm seeing like
patients coming in now who've had back
pain for three months that they want to
ablate them at an extreme cost when we
know the procedure doesn't work and then
spine surgery for non-h herniated disc
without ridicul opathy outcomes are
terrible in short and long I mean
shortterm and long term and nobody looks
at long-term outcomes and to be honest
the only measure that matters to me is
long-term outcome we know facet
injections don't work we've known that
for 30 years
but we pay for those things and and I
presented at one of our meetings like
how many acupuncture appointments I can
have with a patient for the cost of one
epidural injection and I and I sit there
and I go I could treat a person for a
whole year with acupuncture for the cost
of one injection and I there's okay
evidence on acupuncture it's at least as
good if not better than um the evidence
for neuro and and epidural injection and
and stuff like that so then the next
question I come down to is well why do
we pay for neuro oblation but we don't
pay for acupuncture and I don't get that
and I do get it I do totally understand
it it's in my book read my book but
anyway I'm selling my book here on I
guess so now that's a disclosure but I I
I don't make any money off of it but I'm
just saying it's a good book Dr thanks
but I I just trying to figure out like
it and I know the answer but it's to me
if to answer your question
representative is that we need to change
a system and I don't think this bill is
going to make that change I I don't
think it will either I think
philosophically we just kind of where
we're drifting
to
um people have asked me about Medicare
for all and would that solve the problem
and I said well they solve the access
problem to some degree but it's not
going to solve the finance problem we're
a consumer-driven society and when you
allow consumers to consume
they will consume at the same time we
have providers and people in healthcare
that are all predicated upon making the
living off that consumption so until you
figure out how to change those Dynamics
which I don't know how to do
today
so I mean it's it's really simple you
get R rid of fee for service
medicine I mean but it's simple but it's
simple in concept I don't representative
Palmer um I remember in House Bill 66
one of the um last presentation we had
and they talked about first line second
line and third line first line is all
the things we talked about it's massage
it's um ta Chi it's it's helping the
patient at the very beginning of their
Journey Down with pain particular
chronic pain however almost everything
in Silo One is paid out of pocket by the
patient so they don't have any resources
a lot of times to access things in Sil
Silo one so they go to Silo 2 which gets
into the provider part of it and then if
that doesn't work then you go Silo 3
which is what Dr Nel's talking about
Neel is the surgical part and so forth
Etc but we don't do a lot to help the
patient in the first
Silo what I would love to see is that
you know if we're going to seriously
talk about evidence base that we need to
be really open and honest and and submit
everybody to the same Level Playing
Field about evidence that you know if
you're a spine surgeon and you're going
to work B pedicle screws on a
degenerative spine your level of
evidence has to be the same as an
acupuncturist you know their level of
evidence if you're going to supply apply
different levels of evidence then that's
not fair and it's not right and um my
belief personally has been for a very
long period of time that
um that the money that we spend on those
things if you shifted that money to
these other things and Bill you talked
about
prevention like the national pain
strategy prevention was one of the six
pillars and when we're talking about
like um the opioid abatement commission
and the governor's Commission on alcohol
prevention is a big pillar so we looked
at where the gaps were there's like
nothing in prevention it's like well
that's crazy I mean if you start hitting
things like early on cost effective and
I'm going to share one story so I was
out to dinner with u my my my uh friends
and my friend's mom was with him and and
and and his wife threw her back out at
the dinner table and I'm sitting here
this world renowned expert on back ha
and I'm sitting how am I going to take
care of this my friend's mother said
here just do this and she did in her
back pain was fine that was free I mean
that was amazing but I realize how
stupid I
thought I had in my mind was something
complicated whereas all she needed was
something was that evidence based
totally cuz I was watching it it was
like but I I'm I'm always struck by how
many times we apply complex solutions to
simple problems that cost it I mean
every day I see patients $10,000 spended
for a problem that could have been fixed
for for like an ibuprofen prescription
it's crazy have go back to what
represent Palmer said
it goes back to FIFA service um I I
don't disagree at all I think that's one
of the concerns we all have
is how do you incentivize somebody to do
things without getting into being
compensative for every single which it
you
do well I mean because it's a double the
other side of fee for service is that
there are some things that are that we
pay a lot for mostly procedures and
other things we pay very little for so
they don't happen I mean the best
example I'm thinking is just talking to
a gast gastrologist a few years ago and
you know I I just wanted a consult on a
patient I didn't want to proceed her and
he said well I'll I'll do a curbside but
I don't you know it's not worth it to me
to do the consult and you just go like
that's you know he should he I mean it
does I mean not that you want the person
who's doing the colonoscopy to be really
good at it but I thought the reason that
they got the extra training was so that
they could think about the GI problem
and they should get paid the same for
you know within you know within reason
and and that's that's a huge part of and
that actually that's I mean that's a
national problem that's got to get fixed
at a whole different level
but but that's also I think why I'm so
looking forward to House Bill 66 and
talking about trying to create something
that's fundamentally different um and
pilot program and try to understand how
we can get again a small scale work on
it and find out at that point in time
are the things we're advocating for in
fact do they either reduce cost or do
the same cost Factor but actually get
better outcomes and I think that's what
we're trying to do on a small scale
without trying to change the whole
system but look at a small piece of
it and that's back to the same thing you
talking about represent Palmer it's the
fundamental Al issue of compensation and
it's not just looking at and saying who
is driving the compensation because like
in hospice I think you're probably aware
of you get a bundle payment but the
hospice organization is the one that's
determining how to utilize those
resources not have something
micromanaged you know this is really a
scary conversation to me because I think
what we're doing has a lot of value and
this discussion has a lot of
value but unless you convince people to
do the things that we want them to do or
trying to encourage them to do unless we
give them a financial incentive to do it
they won't do it and Mur said something
earlier that bothered me a lot but I
know it's true is that if you're in a
small hospital and you you lose your hip
replacement dock all of a sudden your
hospital goes belly up and I sit there
and I go that's really sad that you put
so many eggs in one basket that you're
going to put the risk of the entire
Health Care Network in your community at
risk just because one guy can't do one
procedure you know I I I I don't know
these are you're right these are
problems I don't think 303 was going to
solve any of that but I and I these are
Big questions and I'm really glad we had
this discussion I'll make a motion on
the floor to recommend
itl you thanks since it came from you I
feel
better I I really don't want to be the
one to do that thank you I'll put
representative Merchant with a Target on
his
back I can second so when it whatever
rebounds off him hits me yeah thanks so
the motion on the floor is itl by
represent Merchants second to by
represent plumber yep and the vote is
going to be three Z or two why we do a
two to one two to one that's F yeah I
don't mind I I I was a 19 to one on one
vote I was still proud of
that I know I was right you guys are all
wrong yeah motion to adjourn motion is
accepted
thanks